ladies and gentlemen I'm Greg Alva and
I'm Spyder John we have watched
spider-man into the spider-verse and let
me tell you to follow us on the Stardust
at people download it it's free to use
there's so many people wanted we post 30
second reaction reviews for films TV
shows and trailers have a great time
doing it it's also a lot of micro
sketches it's worth our time it's worth
your time and you can post your own
reactions as well and if we'd like you
enough we just might follow you isn't
that something special anyway onto into
the spider verse I'll tell you guys man
every once in a while I walk into a
movie and I go wow haha over rated this
is not the case see what I did i defied
expectations there cuz I'm that
brilliant I think this is most likely
the best comic book movie of 2018 I
think you might be right I've seen
infinity war three times in the theaters
oh snap and venom once do some giant
breakdown and recover all the Easter
eggs that's gonna be impossible if you
look at this scene in the background I'm
sure you've already heard a bunch of
non-spoiler reviews of this movie or not
the first review you're clicking on not
gonna go over all the story detail
elements of eight of what the plot set
up it is one of the things I really
really dug about this movie was the
storyline to it I was really wildly
impressed with how well they juggled so
many different characters yeah it's easy
to assume that this might be something
that's like very over convoluted but I
think in in the right way it's very
concise everything's very tight which
surprised me and I think it's because
all the other Spider Man characters in
this movie are already very experienced
they already know the game very well and
what makes it such a great journey for
miles till the very end of the movie is
miles is someone who doesn't have any
experience with this and he's constantly
learning throughout and he doesn't even
get his suit to like the
finale of the movie exactly I mean you
really are watching the origin of this
kid as he's thrust into a situation and
as he's learning yet from all the
different characters around him and that
makes him a very clear and very
relatable protagonist because he's kind
of a fish out of water everywhere he
goes they did a great job at having this
ticking clock of what must be done and
in the midst of that him having to learn
how to be spider-man while so
introducing surprise villains surprise
spider-man characters all throughout and
yeah the animation in this film is just
dazzling it's spectacular really cool
it's like this mixture of 2d and 3d it
feels like a comic book I felt like
nothing could ever really tops in city
in terms of live-action of looking like
a comic book but this one in terms of an
animation Wow I've just never ever seen
anything like it has the best opening
credits and the best ending credits yeah
it really feels like a comic book page
just started to move in a totally
different way than a lot of the other
stuff we've seen thus far and you have
the different characters and the other
dimensions and the style changes with
them as well which is part of the fun
because the animation is so bright and
beautiful and Elsa borrows from graffiti
art neon colors and things like that
there's a definite graffiti and hip-hop
slant to a lot of the aesthetics and
whatnot and it makes for a really cool
unique vibe as well as just a classic
Spiderman vibe yeah like it does both
really well it's fun but it also has
some decent emotional weight to it you
know in the journey that miles has to go
on and what's at stake for him it's very
dark at certain moments yeah like I
think something I don't hear a lot of
people really talking about harshaali
plays Aaron Davis who is the Prowler if
you've read any backstory on who the
Prowler is you know that in the movie
real it doesn't treat you and over again
yeah movie doesn't treat the audience in
a way as if oh they already know they
treated like a big twist reveal because
the twist reveal for Miles Morales is
character
yeah that's appropriate for the people
who aren't aware that's gonna hit and
for us who are aware it is well
foreshadowed yes you know cuz I found
myself really enjoying the movie a hell
of a lot before Jake Johnson Peter
Parker showed up because you have the
Chris Pine Peter Parker which threw me
off because I you were able to tell us
Chris Pine I couldn't but I knew it
wasn't Jake Jake
yeah exactly I was like wait a minute
that's not him
yeah yeah it was in tune with the Peter
Parker that eventually becomes the main
Peter Parker in the movie yeah it's like
this is an alternate Peter but not
that'll the very confident heroic
version what I love what they do a Peter
Parker in this though this is the adult
spider-man yeah I love that the other
spider-man movies they always start off
when they're really young but even with
Tobey Maguire by the time he gets to
spider-man 3 he still feels like the
young oh yeah yeah you know a young man
but this Peter Parker they're the Jake
Johnson version he spent time with is
married had my divorce since he's like
taking time on trying to get into it
again is when I saw the trailer and I
wasn't trying to feel about this like
lazy spider-man character but he's so
funny it's such a refreshing take even
on Peter Parker it's not just the Miles
Morales element in this crazy multiple
universe element that makes it so unique
and refreshing even the take on Peter
Parker is refreshing in this one
oh yeah well in this movie allows for
them to do a lot of pretty interesting
and and broad things not everybody would
want that flavor of spider-man just to
be the definitive one but it works
really well for this movie and it's not
overbearing yes you have all the
different personalities together and you
know you've got Gwen - who's a little
more of a focal character her vibe that
she brings to the movie and then you
know you got the other ones to fill in
sort of yeah yes I was surprised because
the trailer was good at concealing stuff
I didn't expect for us to actually have
this universe as Peter Parker died
upfront and have to deal with that
because there is a way to beyond just
him getting the power and wanting to use
that power for something and find
meaning in it but it's also like he
witnessed the loss of this universe is
spider-man which gives a good purpose
and motivation for Miles Morales yeah I
love that little nugget of when you know
Mary Jane's giving a public speech
everyone's wearing their Spiderman car
which by the way features it's amazing
Stan Lee cameo yes eventually it fits no
refunds it's funny because you kind of
get this mixture of all of a lot of what
Stan Lee sort of represents in that
moment because that that fits in tune
with who's spider-man is
actually it fits yeah it's a cheeky joke
but it also rings true yes yeah I really
appreciate that cameo yeah this main
character Myles who already is trying to
find his own identity and then you got
Peter Parker who has his own Redemption
path tail and then with the other
spider-man characters I love how they
always reintroduce them let's do this
one last time yeah yeah and you see like
the different origin of it and I love
the joke of you know you get the Peter
Parker one the one that's kind of
playing on things we've seen for the
other spider-man movies you know the
spider-man dance that was for me yeah
you get the other one with the Peter
Parker from Jake John yeah which is
playing on the same path a lot more
realistic a lot less exciting and a lot
more just kind of regular very
depressing stuff I really like Spiderman
noir yeah I think out of all the others
spider-man he was the standout one for
me what makes him so funny is how
serious he takes himself yeah yeah and
he is one of the like him and spider-ham
I thought were the comic ones and then
the girl with the robot penny Parker I
thought she was like the one who has
like the muscle you know because yet the
all-purpose tool there you know
spider-gwen this is badass
everyone's awesome in this movie it made
me want to see a spider glam but yeah
that's something I know you want to see
all of these I'm gonna tell you like
it's been a long time since I've seen a
movie that concludes and I go like the
possibilities are endless and there's so
much you can do with this conceit mixing
a few Spider Men together like okay we
got cliffhanger so we gotta watch the
next one it's overall this movie just
had the right pitch of everything like
it's just self-aware enough it's fun
enough and also weighty enough there's
some actual relevant character stuff for
miles oh it's so funny yeah it's funny
and it does the villains great too
because not only do you have the Prowler
stuff but you got kingpin I've been
saying for the longest time that I have
anyone from those like TV shows a Marvel
that should be in the MCU it should be
kingpin and
and I always go back to when I grew up
on the spider-man cartoon kingpin was
one of the main villains I would love to
see kingpin in one of these movies and
then sure enough it's spider-verse that
gives us that villain I've heard some
complaints about him being under ridden
I can feel that I liked him died them I
felt like he did the kingpin job I don't
know if that's coming from the fact that
people watch daredevil and kingpins so
freaking flushed out but I felt for what
the position is kingpin plays in this
movie I was totally satisfied with him I
liked his design he said he's got like a
whole body and there's a head the screen
literally and I also think that yeah
while they that is a reasonable
criticism of that character I do think
that in the villains Department this
movie still gets a good weightier
villain with the prowlers yeah because
they spend time just letting him and
miles hang out just him as Aaron Davis
and and bond together and that's some
really effective stuff's about the movie
cuz that goes back to his family life
and his relationship with his dad was
actually surprised when Prowler was
killed yeah I liked the way they handled
that moment of he takes off the mask
then he slowly puts it back on him yeah
I think it shot it was pretty sad I'm
glad I'm so glad if this movie didn't
end with it's some cliffhanger of oh no
the dad's gonna be hunting down
spider-man now as that for a hot second
I thought that's where it was headed
yeah me too and I haven't I like that
there's an arc there's a resolution to
how he feels about spider-man he's
essentially gonna be like it's Jim
Gordon in a way yeah and I really like
both of the aspect like his dad at odds
with spider-man stuff but also just his
relationship with his family I thought
was really well done it felt very real
very natural yeah and I like Tigers half
black half latina which is entombed with
a comics yeah but it's cool they kept it
in the movie yeah there's so much color
and flavor to this movie and there's so
many things to point to and be like this
is really great about this it's really
magical and yeah you just leave dazzled
and the finale of the movie - it was
interesting watching this movie because
I felt like a lot of times in these
origin movies they've really like
fulfill their organs are pretty early on
yeah like beginning of act 2 or middle
go back to their that character master
the power it was it was cool that when
he finally Dawn's the suit
actually the first trailer we got for
into the spider-verse and i forgot about
that
so in the suit showed up on screen do
something it's rewarding you know yeah
because they're really good at their
jokes with familiarity like when he's
about to go make his first big jump yeah
yeah it's like it's it knows when to be
real and when to be kind of lived in
yeah
cheeky sort of way I love this surprise
of the Doc Ock because I felt like they
really kept I couldn't remember that in
the trailers because I was looking at
some scenes that we've seen I don't
remember seeing this dawn voice ER which
is great you get so many spiderman
characters we also get like these cool
nuggets of villains were so cool to look
at yeah in a different way than the
live-action stuff does it this is really
able to make it feel like a comic book
world where all the villains can exist
and it's not weird to think about like
well wouldn't there be other villains or
were the other people you could talk
about kingpin being under a dome like
you know we also got two other visually
interesting still intimidating and serve
the purpose and by the time you get to
the finale where they're like battling
inside of that weird the Hadron Collider
yeah that was intense somebody killed
spider-man in the beginning of the movie
oohs whoa that's the other thing too is
like in contrast to a lot of superhero
movies you feel the weight of a lot of
those things in just a way that struck
me as being kind of different than a lot
of the other like world you even get a
different version of Aunt May that he
was subtly done it was just like yeah I
mean on this yeah like it was kind of
like also an Alfred to in a totally bad
ass kind of way and it nods you know
cheekily to all the different aspects of
spider-man like it especially when they
go down in the cave and it's kind of
like the motorcycle in the buggy and if
you look in the backgrounds of most all
the scenes you're gonna find interesting
little Easter eggs the addition of Miles
Morales has powers too of the fact that
he can go invisible the electricity
power he has of how that became such an
integral part of his growth when Peter
Parker like sweeps him and he's like
until you can go stealth on command like
all those things
Sonne how they handle the powers that
they're so internal with how his mindset
does yeah that's a little like go and
have faith in all these things it has to
grow yes we'll meet the occasion yeah
and then you get this like hilarious
post-credits scene to with Miguel romera
Miguel Harry yeah which is like whew
she's like it's the future which I found
is Oscar Isaac I guess so because I saw
Oscar Isaacs name listed as interesting
person number one on the credits and I
was like oh that's weird and then I
found out oh that's officer I liked I
read on some article that that was oh
yeah I mean that was such a funny
post-credits too because just the payoff
is amazing yeah but it goes back to the
meme yeah this were a real episodes sexy
show oh yeah yeah just inserted him into
it but like I appreciate it they went
the extra mile to make a post-credits
that's cool and exciting but not
necessarily an ad for something and
ultimately just becomes a really funny
joke this is a movie that I could talk
about forever I bought tickets for
things like twice like infinity war I
bought tickets twice already a mess I
knew I just had to watch it again yeah
this is the first movie in a long time
years I'm talking where I watch it and
right when I'm leaving I'm already on my
phone trying to find tickets for another
the one like criticism outside of the
movie that I feel like this could run
into is kind of a Tim Bergen Nightmare
Before Christmas situation cuz everyone
kind of associate is as a phil lord
chris miller join when i'm like yeah you
know one could say their fingerprints
are all over this which I've heard quite
a few people say exactly like that but
it's not just their film like they're
not even there's three directors and
they're not any of them know and I don't
remember any other Tim Burton over
because that everyone marks of their
sensibility but yeah no mad props
there's different writers on there
totally has its own vibe and it does
feel very
crafted I don't know it feels very much
like it has its own unique voice and I
do think yeah that those directors
definitely deserve some credit this is
one of the reviews that when
I am editing this I'm gonna look back
and go should I mention this should have
mentioned this should have mentioned it
I know it's gonna be that but right now
these are yeah I know the feeling
I love this removing I do it was special
alright guys what's your favorite part
about spider-man in this spider-verse
leave your comments down below you guys
can subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell and download and
false in the start us after daily people
your